i spent too much of my life trying to
make it
better easier simpler to get a thing
done myself
and not nearly enough time focused on
how do you get results just to flow to
you whether you're sleeping or not
whether you're thinking about it or not
and that's the difference between being
able to make a 2x contribution in your
life and a 10x or 100x is if you can
construct systems hire the right people
get the right teams in place
empower them in the right way they can
produce results while you're sleeping or
not
last time we were talking you were in
workout gear
do you remember i kind of live in
workout gear
yeah that's my um that's kind of my yeah
but you were you were like cut off at
the shoulders
oh it was boiling hot that's why it was
unbelievably hot i couldn't bear the
heat in newcastle for the first time
ever
and i was overdressed too i was it's in
the pandemic but i could you know you
can take
you can take the englishman out of
england but not how do you say that but
not the englishman out of the man that's
not really a great
quip there but but uh but i was dressed
like i had a jacket on
i was like overdressed for california
and for some reason i was still in that
mode
of so we were anyway it's great to be
with you that's what i'm trying to get
to
good well we're talking about a new book
today
effortless very very excited
for this to come out i'm a huge fan of
essentialism it's one of the
foundational books that i give to people
when they ask what
i want to get into personal development
what what should i read
and essentialism's there so
what's the story of how you came to
realize that you needed to write this
new book well
partially it was essentialism's fault um
you know essentialism changed everything
for me i'm traveling all over i'm
teaching all over the world and i want
to be doing that i'm
not just the father of essentialism by
that point i'm
a father of four children a lot of
responsibilities
and uh and and i really started
finding myself with this question
of like what do you do if there are just
too many
essentials if you've stripped away from
your life the non-essentials i mean i
had chosen not to write another book i
had chosen not to do a workshop business
i'd
put on hiatus the
stanford class that i co-created all
in the spirit of removing non-essentials
but what happens if what you're left
with
in fact is still more than you
can do and in the midst of thinking
about that
i find out that my one of my daughters
is um was literally having a massive
tonic clonic seizure
at home while i'm traveling and
that just pushed me over the edge really
and you know felt
really like i sort of hit a wall or
rather the walls were closing in around
me and i found myself saying well
now what like essentialism takes you to
a certain place
i think it's necessary but i started to
feel it was necessary but insufficient
and i set on a journey really first of
all just to
maintain my own sanity and health
and then the same for my own family
for what do you do when life
is really hard life is hard for everyone
and in hundreds of different ways
what do you do in that situation it's
important life feels hard
how can you make progress in that
situation do you just give up on the
essentials
i think a lot of people do that that was
a tempting
thing for me in that environment or do
you find
an easier path and if i use george
eliot's
you know idea on that for a moment what
do we live for if not to make life
easier for each other and so at first it
was for me
my own family for our business but also
now for other people and and it turns
out that this book is coming out at a
time that i think that may be
especially timely because of the year
the pandemic um and
i just think people are burned out
everywhere or on the edge of being
burned out and so
this this other part this other way of
doing things
suddenly seems to have the power of
relevancy i felt like i was maybe
before like a
like a weight lifter who's lifting with
their back or swimmer who's not
breathing properly or a baker who's
needing by hand it's like you can do the
right things
but if you do them in the wrong way
things will be harder than they need to
be
and so the the positive way of saying
that is that when you can't push any
harder
you can find an easier path a more
effortless path and and there's
practical principles and practices for
how to do that and that's what this book
is all about
it feels to me a little bit like
effortless is a delivery mechanism
so if you had essentialism as a
philosophy
as something that was conceptual perhaps
you could call that like the virus
but the delivery mechanism still needed
to be there a way that allowed you to
integrate this as easily as possible
into the system
um yeah it it's very interesting
thinking about the challenges that you
go through in effortless because so many
of them are so common
to people that live life of productivity
talking about
burnouts talking about this bizarre um
preconception we have that things have
to be hard the right way is the hard way
this puritan work ethic
so much stuff so i want to i want to get
into that you split
the approach up into three sections so
you've got effortless
state effortless action and effortless
results so
effortless state first what's that
well if you you put it this way some of
the mystics would describe there being
only two states in the world
you either have a state of suffering uh
or what i'm calling here
an effortless state and really those are
your two
options um when
the the the state of suffering is where
you're exhausted
mentally uh physically
emotionally you you're carrying grudges
you're angry in the world you're so
tired you start to resent everyone and
anything that's coming at you
and it's just such an that that state
produces a whole set of
actions and results and
none of that is optimal you you you end
up for a lot of overachievers
they respond to those challenges by
pushing even harder
and they just get to the idea that
everything in life has to be hard and if
it's not hard it can't be important
you just get down this sort of
hyperactivity
path and it doesn't produce the results
that you want so that's
that's sort of option a
option b is that an effortless state is
when you're physically rested
uh you're emotionally free
um i was talking with the tim ferriss on
his podcast just recently and
i asked him i said how much what
percentage of your mental and emotional
energy
have you used like have been used up by
anger and grudges
and he said from the age of 15 to 30
he estimates probably between 60 and 70
percent of his mental and emotional
energy
was used upon grudges and anger let me
imagine i mean that's just
that is just mad but but
you you can see that's why effortless
state is the beginning of the model
that's why
why why this is so vital is that you
can't control all the hard things that
happen to you
right for sure not all right i've used
one example for me
in in just summary when my daughter
suddenly has what turned out to be
massive neurological problems over the
like a multi-year experience
um that changed her personality
her physicality everything right like
you can't
change that at first we couldn't do
anything about
it so what you can do is you can make it
as easy as possible to handle it you can
make sure that you don't
make it worse by the way you respond to
it
and and i think the first thing you do
when those things happen in life when
the challenges come
is that is that by getting into the
right state about them
you can start to remain in a creative
state
an open state grateful state
and that will put you in a better
position to be able to know the right
action to take
and and therefore increase your chances
of getting good results out of it
the biggest identification the one that
really struck home with me is
the fact that people assume that the
right way
is inevitably the harder one it's right
such a common mindset
and i've seen this in myself so much
throughout my
uh as my vintage has increased
as an entrepreneur i've managed to cast
it off but every young entrepreneur
knows this they they realize that hard
work
can get you some success right
then which i agree with yeah
then they associate the success with
the hard work itself then they get rid
of the success and just leave the hard
work there
i remember i used to i used to feel
guilty if we'd had a successful event at
one of our nights
if it had gone well but i hadn't
suffered
i used to feel guilty because i thought
no it
it should be more difficult than this if
i haven't stayed up until five in the
morning doing the accounts if there
hasn't been some sort of catastrophe
that i've had to deal with
i think it it must have felt like um
i've got headroom above me i could have
done more
somewhere i could have and it's like are
you telling me that you're complaining
because things went well
looking back with perspective that's
what it was but yes so many people
assume that the right way
is inevitably the harder one
i remember somebody saying to me a fan
of essentialism they said
sensualism is so great but it will be
the hardest it should come with a
warning this will be the hardest thing
that you'll
ever do and for a while i just absorbed
that like
oh yeah i should tell people that and i
actually for a while i did
and then i thought what what madness
this is
why do i just have to assume that it has
to be the hard path
in fact i was saying that even though
the last quarter of essentialism
is is already devoted to the idea of how
do you make
execution of what matters most easier
and and i thought that that's just an
assumption that
just lives everywhere and basically
a hundred percent of the time it remains
unquestioned
just started a new
asked to be on a committee this uh this
council
and uh this this new app that
they're trying to create for uh for
youth all over the world they think it
can make a difference to millions of
people
a positive difference and and at the end
they say well now listen this is so
important it's going to be really really
hard to make this happen
and and no one said anything and in
previous versions of me i wouldn't have
said anything either or thought anything
but now with this new mindset i i just
why does it have to be does it have to
be
in fact it's interesting because in the
same speech they said when they were
asked themselves to lead this effort
the person that had asked them to do it
said how do you feel and they said well
yes i'm willing to do it but we're like
with fear and trembling
and they said well they said well
hopefully with some joy though too
right and that's the thing is this idea
that the more important is the harder it
has to be
think how limiting that is it's one of
the things that i think people can do to
immediately start applying essentialism
and effortless is basically identify
one thing that's essential that you know
if you did it consistently would
be a game changer for you and then the
second question is only two questions
the second is how can you make that
effortless
because it interrupts all the normal
mind flow of like okay yes i want to do
this but it's big hard lifting i've got
to get to the top of everest yeah but
how do you make it effortless oh you
could get a helicopter to the top of
everest oh
that i was just talking to somebody who
works in special ops
well they did for years they're out of
special ops now but been in military for
years and years
i mean that's a place that emphasizes
all the time
that you have to work hard harder harder
harder to achieve results right that
that is a
theme and again there's a place for it
but it it runs out of its usefulness as
a strategy
early on and he told me this story about
when they they used to say he's deployed
in afghanistan in iraq and they used to
be responsible in the special ops team
to get through you know some
metal door to find some value high value
asset
someone on the other side and how they
would do that is they would
put explosives on the the
hinges they blow it and that's how you
get through
where you've got a hole in the wall
you you have a lot of blowback from that
you've let the entire
neighborhood know you're there not yeah
that could be a very dangerous pop
proposition as well you can hurt both
the soldiers and the people on the other
side innocent people can get hurt
so this is the solution right that's one
way but then someone else on his team
said well
you know actually i'm the son of a
carpenter and and i
if you could just get me a small
hydraulic drill i
just get those hinges off in like half a
second be silent be easy there's no risk
to anyone
and that idea just even the idea that
there's a more effortless way to achieve
your objective
is so rarely advocated for
or utilized that we don't even we're
just not even asking the question
so if if hard work equals success then
what happens if you want to be very
successful well therefore you have to
work very hard what if you want to be
very very successful
now you have to work very very very hard
and so on and and so it goes
and this is what i think accounts for a
lot of burnout and otherwise
well-intended good people entrepreneurs
you know is is that they've got this
faulty idea
and then you look at some of the people
that actually are incredibly successful
you look at a warren buffett
how does he approach it does he say well
i want to i want to be very very
successful therefore i'm going to
you know kill myself is that his
approach is that what he says is that
what he's done
no he says that their investment
strategy borders on lethargy
there's an amazing statement lethargy
what is that this is another word for
like laziness
for effortlessness he said we are not
interested in finding
seven foot
holes not poles to jump over
fences to jump over we're not looking
for investment opportunities we have to
jump seven feet in the air
we're looking for investment
opportunities that are one foot
high that we can step over and that is
like a
huge key to their tremendous success is
that they're
looking for the things that are clear
yeses that
are easy yeses and that they can that
they can go big on because
it's just right there in front of them
that's what they're looking for
they distrust the other stuff there's a
different
way and you must find it if you want to
escape the level of success you're
currently at
if you can't push any harder
don't try to push any harder
open yourself to a new question how can
this be easier how could this be
effortless what might how can we make
this more enjoyable
these questions
open your mind to new answers and new
possibilities
how can people let go of the emotional
tether that they have to their puritan
work ethic it's all well and good
me and you sitting here and saying
there's an easier way you don't need to
burn yourself out
but what if it's chris from seven or
eight years ago
who has this emotional attachment it's
almost where he gets his sense of
self-worth from he has anxiety when he's
not
doing that how do they let go
i was coaching somebody um
kim who's a manager at a university
she's responsible for lots of different
uh teams and she was just
like the type of person you're
describing if she
she felt guilty if she stopped to eat
lunch
no no no i don't mean stopped i mean if
she ate lunch
she felt guilty she was the type of
person who
she's up at 4am in the morning
photoshopping
for a young woman's activity at church
the next day she's just like
if she's not exhausted she feels guilty
and that's that's who we're talking to
here but i think a lot of people are in
that category even if they're not quite
as extreme as her they don't do it quite
the way she does
there is this deep mentality
and one of the things that i would say
to you
and i said to her is like well don't
over complicate
your way out of this don't assume that
the way out of this
deep mindset has to be painful hard
wrenching
difficult at all that that's just
reapplying
the same logic that got you into the
state what if you all you have to do is
ask a different question
what if that's the that's the difference
and that is what that's what i asked her
to do i said i said the next time
somebody asked you to do something
just ask yourself you can write on a
sticky note you can put it on your some
way to remember
to ask yourself look what would this
look like if it was easy
is there an easy solution is there an
effortless way of doing this
so she gets a call from one of the
professors at the university he says
look i'd like
you to get your videography team to come
and record
um my class this semester and she just
immediately goes into
her overachiever overthinker over
deliverer
mentality that's well-worn path for her
she immediately she's thinking okay i'll
get the whole team involved they'll go
down there they can we get a couple of
different angles
we'll edit it all together we're going
to add music we'll have intros outros
graphics we're going to wow him he's
going to
love us he's going to be so impressed
you know that's what he's got she's
going for
and then she remembers the one interrupt
the one question well how
is there an effortless way to do this
might there be an easier
way and so she put that to him or what
what might be an easy solution well as
they talk about it
it turns out that it's just one student
who has some athletic commitments which
mean they won't be able to be in every
class but they need this class to
graduate and he's just trying to
accommodate this one student
for some of the classes and so the
solution they come up with on the phone
is that another student will just record
it on an iphone
and send it afterwards whenever he
misses and that totally solves it it
hadn't occurred to him
wouldn't have occurred to her hadn't at
that point she hangs up and she's just
like what just happened in 10 minutes
we have solved the problem that would
have been four months of work
with all those extra bells and whistles
so i actually do
think that just inverting the question
from why does this have to be so hard or
how can i over deliver or how can i
do you just say well how can it be
easier what would it look like if it was
easy
what what what is an effortless solution
to this
and what i will say from my own life my
own life feels
way more complicated still than it ought
to be loads of stuff feels harder than
it ought to be
that's why i wrote the book i wrote it
for me i wrote for other people in that
situation that is our life
right now but i also think the other
side of it is that every day i'm using
these questions now
and i personally find them almost
magical i i can't just can't believe how
often
if i pause and ask the question
something will come forward that just is
would was always there as an option but
i didn't see it
um a silly example is a at a printer on
my desk i
that not on their desk on the floor in
my office over here
been there two weeks i like to keep
things organized and
and every time i see it it was just
enough complication in my mind about
oh do you sell it do you do do you throw
it away if i throw away after my
recycling since i don't know where that
is so
and there's this whole that all like
took two seconds my head but it was
enough to go oh yeah i'm coming back to
that later for two weeks i'd done that
because again all the all the extra
stuff in my head all that noise
and i asked the question is there
effortless way i look outside there
happen to be a couple of workers out
there
i don't know them but they're just out
there and i'm like i wonder if they want
it so i walk
outside hey i've got this printer it's
working but it's been replaced do you
want it yes
i'll walk inside get it give it to them
within literally two minutes of asking
the question i don't just have the
solution that solution is
is executed done and that
that you can say it's a silly example
but a small example
but that is life is made up of those
things that are just harder than they
ought to be
and we make them harder than they need
to be and it's because
we're asking the wrong questions and if
we can change the question if we can
invert it
you'll be amazed at what is possible
that
isn't possible if you're doing it the
hard way
trying to just bookend what we said
there and give people a scalable
takeaway from that section
each of the different solutions that you
need are
because each situation is different that
the guys that
you need to give the printer to aren't
the solution to the lady that needs to
film the video stuff
but the scalable solution is inverting
the question
instead of saying why is this so hard
why is this uncomfortable
what would it look like if this was
easier
what would this situation look like if
it wasn't so hard if it wasn't going to
be painful if it wasn't going to be a
slog what would this situation look like
yes it is simply in many instances in
your life
when something when you have something
that's expensive that you weren't
expecting something to be expensive for
something
so somebody gives you some proposal for
something it was much more than you were
hoping it would be
just ask the question well is there an
effortless solution what
might be an effortless solution to this
problem that happened
southwest airlines uh the the the
low-cost carrier they're trying to
be careful on how they spend money
everyone else at the time is using a
complex expensive ticketing system
and it's going to cost them two million
dollars to install it
they don't want to spend that two
million dollars but they're worried that
they're gonna go out of business if they
can't be competitive in
in and then certainly somebody says
what's an easy solution we said well i
guess the effort the solution would be
we don't care what anyone else thinks a
ticket is
we don't care what continental thinks a
ticket is and they're like yeah we don't
care we're not interested in that
and so they got rid of that complexity
that that clutter by asking that
question
and what they came up with is they said
well we already give people receipts
so we'll just print on the receipt this
is your ticket and we'll skip the whole
two million dollar system
all that complexity all that time all
that effort just resolve it's just done
so the question yes the takeaway is ask
a better question
ask an effortless question and you open
yourself
up to possibilities and solutions that
will come to you
that won't otherwise come to you that
that is the takeaway yes
if you roll it forward over time if you
spend too much time
doing effortful living effortfully
uh as opposed to effortlessly you end up
with burnout
and you have a quote in the book that
burnout is not a badge of honor
and that is an absolute bar that's so
correct when i think about some of the
young entrepreneurs that i know
who see it as a rite of passage who see
the late nights and the early starts as
a rite of passage and it takes time
to get i don't know whether i don't know
whether it's a byproduct of the fact
that
when you get towards your 30s you become
chronically aware of your own mortality
and late nights just annihilate you
but um there is a an awakening
like a uh a mano pause for the men um
that occurs around that time and you
think god
like this sucks and i've had those
periods i've had those burn out periods
um for the type a go-getters
or the people that like to overwork how
can you
deliver them the red pill on burnout and
also what are some of the signals
the early signals of burnout and the
warning signs that you notice and take
heed of
yeah so first of all that last point
one of the one of the trickiest things
about burnout is that the closer we get
to it
the worse we are at discerning it
and because because the problem with
burnout is it's affecting your own
ability to think
it changes the way you are experiencing
your life
so you're that that's what the research
shows the closer you had to burn out the
less likely you are to actually notice
it
um so this is
so this is one of the reasons that that
you sort of need to develop a heightened
awareness
um things that you can do i mean i mean
one test
that i like is am i used did i use up
more
energy today than i can recuperate today
a similar question can i did i use up
more physical emotional energy this week
than i can recuperate this week
because some days you are going to and
even some weeks you're going to you know
there are
rhythms to life of course there are
times that there is a sort of big push
moment but you don't want to live your
life in that
place because then you won't be
you won't get to choose when you have to
stop
it will eventually be chosen for you but
you'll also
be choosing the highest cost path by the
time you stop
you just look at what your relationships
look like with the people that matter
most to you
you look like look at what your overall
health is
you look at what your overall life ex
life quality is
you won't be happy with the results of
that by the time you're forced to stop
so i think that's one test about it
i think a second test that i like for
burnout is like when you start to resent
people
when any request that comes to you just
just irritates you
bothers you my goodness just another
thing another thing
that's a good signal that you are burned
out
once you know when when somebody's moved
something in your in your home
and you can't find the thing that you
wanted to find and that just drives you
you can't believe he's so frustrated
about this you feel
impatient and so on this is a pretty
good sign that you're that you're burned
out
if you feel like you're using um a lot
of nervous energy
you know that's the fuel that you're
using is nervous sort of anxious energy
stress energy you know again that can
help
to get you through certain things but
you don't want to be
running on that fuel all the time
because that has all sorts of
um negative externalities so
so yeah those are maybe two or three
tests that i think you can use to
kind of start to assess you know am i am
i
you know am i am i on the edge of
burnout or even way past it
if you've got any strategies for how
people can bounce back from burnout
quickly
well i think that the the principle
which we should start with is that
relaxing is a responsibility
so that's a different frame it's not
like a nice thing to do
after the fact it's like real relaxation
is is as important responsibility as any
other venture that you have in your life
um what i would recommend that people do
on this
is that i think that they should start a
little list somewhere between 10 and 20
items
and at first your average overachiever
might not even be able to put one thing
on that list
but the list is what things relax me
what are what is relaxing for me
my wife and i both done this and it's
our list are completely different
it was very helpful for us to have for
ourselves but also for each other
so that if i'm trying to support her
same you could do it with the members of
your team
so that if you're trying to create an
environment that is it
that supports a proper
balance between you know between work
and relaxation
that you actually can have signature
experiences created for them so i know
so my wife's
birthday for example or if i'm just
saying hey you know i can see she's
starting to get a bit burned out
i can look at the list and actually
construct an evening or a day or try and
you know instead of just going oh you
know you should take the day off you
should relax well that's quite stressful
for overachievers
they don't know what to do with that
space it's not it's not that doesn't
that's not going to
you don't want blank space a lot of
people don't
so you actually have to learn relax
relaxing
as its own capability and as i say for
overachievers
that they're more comfortable setting a
goal to run a marathon than they are to
take a nap
[Laughter]
all right take a nap isn't much is it
like what i don't know about that i
don't know if i can do that i don't know
how yeah
that's that's the mission impossible um
and in fact is is one specific thing i
think people
you know if people understood the actual
research around
the value that the return of investment
on taking an effortless nap i think it
would be
they would lean into it more
more easily i'm not always great at
getting the number of hours of sleep i
need at night but
i am like a champion napper and i'm
i i don't i don't even honestly for a
long time i didn't even know that people
thought of that as a bit childish it'll
take a nap but i think that was i think
that's uh
that was like sleep time for my
three-year-old it's like i
i i don't know where i picked it up but
i just 100
believe in it as soon as i feel that
sleep pressure building as it does
through the day naturally
um somewhere in the afternoon oh i'm so
happy to go take a nap i recognize i
will be
twice as productive in the rest of my
day
discernment way better my state can be
restored
even just literally half an hour of
lying down
yeah just talking to somebody the other
day and they said oh yeah if i ever
worked from home i
i used to say if i ever work from home
i'm gonna take a nap every day and in
one year of working from home from
pandemic they've never done it
the opportunity is there now but the
mindset is still
is still built around some other i would
say
industrial age view of productivity
where we treat ourselves like a
like a you know a a mill or a factory
we're neither of those things we're not
a factory we're we're we're humans
with biology and and and the system
needs
times of concentration and times of
relaxation and that is optimal
performance when you can get those two
together
moving on to the next section which is
effortless action
what's that yeah what is that how does
that integrate with where we're at so
far
um effortless state is just you know
always come back to so that when you're
out of that state
you you as we most of us are most of the
time
we just need to keep coming back to it
physically oh i need to i need to take a
nap i'll physically check in
oh i need to i need to eat something i
haven't eaten anything eat something
healthy
um you know that's that's about the sort
of constant adjustment
but as we get into that effortless state
what we want to do
is is to simplify the action itself
so i see i see a lot of the times that
the action
itself is not really the problem
the the problem is getting to it got all
these assumptions it has to be hard you
you're over complicating you're
overthinking and so on
but then when you get to the task itself
people still can
approach that in a way that the action
is is harder and more overwhelming than
it needs to be
so there's a few things here i think
that you can do you can say
you can say well let's do it with you
are you game you're going to do
you're going to you like you love doing
this you did it to me last time let's do
it again i did but i wanted to do it a
little differently today
so so you know back to this question i
asked at the beginning of what
now starting now in your life uh what is
something
yep important game changer something
that you
you know you want to get done
you you you know if you did it
especially if you did it consistently it
would it would make a big impact could
be business personal anything what's the
first thing
let me think uh write
a new lead magnet for my email
newsletter
i know that i know that if i do that
that it will massively bump the number
of subs
that i have on my newsletter i'm already
doing the newsletter so i'm already
doing part of the work and there is a
bottleneck
there's a rate limiting step on the
number of subscribers that i've got
if i release a new lead magnet then and
i know what i want to do i just haven't
started because i just think oh it seems
like a really big task it's going to
take ages
okay a lead magnet for what what you're
describing is literally a
particular type of article it will be a
pdf an offer pdf just a free pdf
downloadable pdf sign up to the
newsletter
and get your pdf got it uh
and so now that's it we've already
identified that now the question is
everything else is about effortless so
the big question as i've already
mentioned is how could we make this
effortless for you
um you know the some of the questions
that could help us answer that
question um well what does done look
like
pdf completed edited
finalized and uploaded onto landing page
integrated with email client ready to go
yeah okay so it's it's it's is it
uploaded in the schedule on your email
client
yeah um what is the
first physical physical obvious action
you can take
the very first one towards that goal
open the note in apple notes on notion
which i'm going to create the outline of
the content of the lead magnet
okay so it's it's just opening the app
that's the first step
what can you achieve in a 10 minute
micro burst on that
you spent 10 minutes the next 10 minutes
you're in there you've got 10 minutes
what could you achieve
the lead magnet is going to be a hundred
books that i think everybody should read
and i could go
through my existing amazon shopping list
which is already on the internet
and i could run through that and take
off the highlights from there i've
already done some of this work
yep um so within 10 minutes
you're not gonna get all hundred in
there probably but you're gonna get
you know you're gonna get what number 20
some
20 between i mean they're there i've got
this there's tons on that list so it
would be pretty easy
yeah so um so
next question so we've identified 20
we've identified a 10 minute thing
um if you worked on it is this something
you would generally want to work on in
one big push
or is it if you worked on this let's say
every day
and you were going to add 20 per day
over a five day period does that feel
sustainable to you
does that feel like yeah i i could
imagine doing that
in that way or is that uncomfortable in
some way
that would probably be fine i'd be
tempted to batch it in a different way
i'd probably get
all 100 listed in one go so that i'm in
one mode of thinking
and then the next one will be to
actually fill out why i think people
need to
read this book and then perhaps another
one after that would be getting the
amazon short links and doing that across
or sending that to someone in the team
and getting them to do that
and then any of the other bit maybe an
intro so just
trying to batch those together but i
think given that they're quite discreet
different tasks i'm pretty certain i
could sit down and
blast through and get all of the books
listed and then maybe the big chunk will
be writing why i think they're good so
maybe we do
you know a couple of hours each day or a
couple of hours every couple of days for
a little while so
so what i'm exploring with you
is is whether there's a an upper bound
that would be helpful
right like the you know lower bound is
that you that you open this app
right like every day you open the app
until it's done
maybe the lower bound even is the 10
minute micro burst that we just talked
about where you say okay for 10 minutes
i'm going to work and you literally time
yourself with that 10 minutes
but here's the key part is that you have
an upper bound and i'm not sure what
that is yet for you but
that you say okay at this point i'm done
because
the temptation is and you already used
it blast through it
and that was the language right i'm
gonna blast through it well i
on days that you don't really have the
time space energy to do that
you think that's the way to make it
happen so then you go well i can't do it
today
because i can't blast through i can't
get those hundred done today
so therefore you don't do it and you're
in the situation that you are describing
so if you have an upper bound and i i
like the timing bound for you on this
because then you say well listen i have
podcast that i'm recording at this time
that is in 20 minutes
but i will i can succeed my goal for the
day because
it's a timed amount of time no matter
how many books i get done or not
it's done by the end of that 20 minutes
that is my goal so i don't know quite
what it is for you with this but it's an
upper bound so that you pace yourself
it's one of the biggest errors i think
of of
of the sort of the exhausting path uh is
that people
push themselves and power through
and what that means is that they just
they can only do it
for a short burst they could only by day
two by day three you
you're just like i don't have an hour or
two to do on this today so i've got to
wait until i have a full hour or two to
do it and i have the energy to do it and
i know somebody pushed on a project like
this the whole weekend they push push
push
and then they just like they couldn't
even think about that project for two
more weeks after that
they didn't get it done and they
couldn't even think about it because it
was too much it was too overwhelming
it just exhausted their mental interest
in that subject
and so that's what i would be suggesting
for you is like a little bit of pacing
okay so what's the right pace for you by
the way what is the upper bound that
sounds right
i think any more than an hour in between
all of the other stuff that i'm doing
especially for the big chunk which is
writing out the descriptions of the
books
i think much more than an hour would
probably i'd start to have a flinch
effect away from it just to interject on
what you said there it feels like um
[Music]
the rev limiter that you have on a car
so it just just allows you to bounce off
the ceiling but what you can do as
opposed to letting yourself get into
that red
is you can actually bring that down and
if you're sufficiently
experienced with how your ebb and flow
of energy works and what you know that
you can tolerate without getting into
burnout
you can take okay i don't want to hit
burnout
which is a particular distance over a
particular amount of time
let's rate that down from a macro
aggregate
into a micro daily and okay okay so
maybe i think
maybe i think i could get away with
adding maybe like half an hour in maybe
i could get away with adding
an hour in so i like i like that i like
a lot of what we're going to talk about
when we get into the final section is
that next action it's what's the
physical thing that you can do
but this is a integrating the
what does done look like which is super
important give yourself license to say
that you have done the work for today
it gives you more freedom by by putting
it into a time constraint
it liberates you from what could be a
really difficult piece of work i might
get to
95 books and think oh god i
i need to find the rest of the books if
i'm working for two hours i've worked
for two hours like that's two hours of
good work
i'm not working to a deadline if there's
an outright deadline and it's three days
away this is a little bit different
but when it's for most people ongoing
tasks that need to be completed as and
is
yeah well i've done two hours on it
should i not feel satisfied with
my two hours of hard work and by
defining done
which i i absolutely love you have to
decide what done
looks like um by doing it within a time
window
you always liberate yourself i feel like
this
this insight i've seen from a couple of
different people yourself and some of my
friends that have it too
and it is um
the thing that all of those people have
in common is they've got quite strong
family lives
i feel like it's a forcing function
it absolutely is whereas yeah i'm sure
when you were
uh young and and didn't have those
responsibilities quite so much and
were sort of still where i'm at now
where i don't have a mrs or kids or a
dog that's knocking on the door saying
we've got such and such as barbecue
tonight
that's when you can just keep nose on
grindstone
and just continue to go away in a way so
i love that define what done looks like
give yourself a window and use windows
of time as
um little mini extrapolated or reverse
extrapolated
uh burnout indicators and use that as a
as a little rev limiter awesome
yeah i mean i think for you i'm i'm i'm
not saying an hour you said an hour
before you flinched is what you
described like
an hour more i started to flinch with
that i think for you it's like half an
hour
it's tops on this assignment you can do
a lot in half an hour i i know you can
you if you start doing this with a half
an hour you'll have a whole thing
and that's fine you leave it there and
you move on
you know you see that the benefit i took
on a big project six months ago
and i knew if i forced it i could get it
done
no actually i thought if i forced it i
could do it maybe three months
but i didn't i said no it's gonna give
yourself the time it's a six month
project
it was a major project at the end of
that six months
i got it done it felt effortless the
journey was effortless it was
really rewarding and really great and
there's other people i know that would
like to do it but it's overwhelming to
even start
and other people i know that started
pushed too hard at the beginning
exact same challenge we're taking and
and
they're they're halfway through now it's
still taken six months but they pushed
hard for three months
didn't get it done and now if semi given
up
and and so this power of pace is not
obvious to overachievers we want to get
it all done now we're going to force it
we're going to push it
you pace yourself you go slow to go
smooth and then
smooth turns out to be fast that's the
military phrase right
go smooth go slow to go slow is smooth
smooth as fast
so that's on the pacing thing but for
you now this is a good transition for
effortless results and the distinction
because effortless action
in the book is really about how you take
one project
one activity and you make it as easy as
possible to complete
there's a very practical section in the
book the third
section of the book is about how can you
use effort in a certain way to make
the results you want flow again
and again and again so that's the
difference between linear
results that is one effort equals one
reward
versus residual results which is you
you maybe even put in a little more
effort at the beginning
takes a little more to set it up but it
flows to you
again and again and again after that and
so i'm not going to give you the
challenge because i've just started to
learn this myself
of a one-click solution for what you
gave to me this lead magnet
article right now we've talked about how
to make it simpler for you to do it
but what i want to know is could you
construct it to the point
you already got members of your team you
already talked about that but could you
construct it to the point where all you
have to do is one click it's a huge
challenge it's a it's way beyond where
you are right now with it
so it's not that you're going to be able
to do that immediately but that you
construct the right people in your team
and you empower them in the right way
that when you say listen i want to do a
lead magnet article on the top 100 books
that they have access to your amazon
page yourself themselves
that they can go through and curate all
of that yourself and bring to you
120 books and and
or even they even they look at your
podcast who you've had on what they know
about you they've done all of that
evaluation for you they bring you 100
books
they've already written a few thoughts
about each of them based on what you've
said on your podcasts
they've done all of that work so that
they bring it to you
now based on my own experience with this
you probably have to do this a few times
on a few projects before they know your
voice know what you're doing know how
you'd
so that but again there could be a point
where in the future
you have the lead magnet and it's a
one-click solution they send it to you
and all you're doing is approve or not
and the whole thing has been done so
that's that's the difference between
effortless action and what i'm
describing is effortless
effortless results and that is the for
me personally the hugest thing in this
book
it's like i spent too much of my life
trying to
make it better easier simpler
to get a thing done myself and not
nearly enough time
focused on how do you get results just
to flow to you
whether you're sleeping or not whether
you're thinking about it or not
and that that that's the difference
between being able to make a 2x
contribution in your life and a 10x or
100x
is if you can construct systems hire the
right people get the right teams in
place
empower them in the right way they can
produce results while you're sleeping or
not
uh you know whether you're focused on it
today or not whether you're taking the
day off whether you're relaxing today
stuff still happens amazing things can
happen
and so i i just put that to you how can
you get to a
one-click solution that would require me
to
finally make the decision to hire an
assistant a full-time ea
which i haven't done yet i don't think
it's
too ridiculous all of the structures are
there the root content that
the team would need is there um
one thing that you may be proud of me
for is i've now
outsourced the production of pretty much
all of my social media content
so we have these beautiful trailers that
are being made by social media guy joe
uh who has come on full time now and
he's he's just phenomenally
listened to the show for for ages so he
understands my voice
he's doing recreationally what he needs
to do for his research for work in any
case
so today he listened to the jordan
peterson episode on the route down to
london to go see his girlfriend
and while he's driving down i'm getting
voice notes from him
saying dude like this bit at 13 minutes
and 45 seconds like i know what i'm
gonna do with that and do this
and it's just i don't need to it's just
hands off
he just makes this beautiful content
from all of the stuff that i already do
then he takes my newsletter because he
gets delivered the newsletter every week
and then he repurposes that into tweet
storms for the following week
because he knows that it's timely and he
knows that it is in my voice
and then he every time he reads the news
so that is
um that's my equivalent i probably would
have said to you
a year ago i want to be able to scale my
exposure on social media and you would
have said
what would have been a one-click
solution for me now it's it's maybe
a voice note in a whatsapp chat
solution so technically one it is one
one click there's maybe some words
but hey mate got this new episode coming
out with greg um
really think that we can like dig some
great content out of this just put it on
your list for next week
done and it'll appear and then it'll
appear on the internet
um so that is one of the things
something that it's a great now go go
just something that is probably lurking
in the back of some people's minds is
they don't
they don't have a team or maybe they're
a one-man band or maybe the tasks that
they have to do they can't outsource to
other people
what's the effortless results
solution for someone that can't
outsource
well effortless results is
you know the can you you can apply it in
any
situation that you're in um
it's really just to do with the mindset
um i mean in your particular instance
uh you know what would a what would a
one-click solution
look like for you without hiring people
is that the question you're asking me
for other people not for me particularly
um
so you just mean in general how can a
person achieve
residual effortless results if they
don't just have
a team that they can hire that's what
you're asking yeah i mean
i would say that no matter what
somebody's
situation is economically
they ought to lean into the idea
of you know of network
uh i i know when i first came to the
united states i mean i literally had no
money at all
so it wasn't like i could have solutions
that looked like oh i'll hire that
person
so exactly as you're saying that
definitely wouldn't have been an option
but i did reach out to i built
started building it you know just i
would
knock on people's doors so to speak i
would call them up
and just network and tell people this is
what i'm trying to achieve i want to
teach i
want to write and so by
by getting to know people beyond your
normal group you are you know to say it
this way i had um
benjamin hardy on the what's essential
podcast and he said
he just wrote a book called who not how
awesome episode
i really enjoyed that thank you chris i
i really like that too i walked away
kind of
changed by that myself and again aware
of how often i was doing
you know making my own action easier
rather than oh just find somebody
that there is a huge network of people
now you certainly don't have to be
hiring someone full time
but taking networking seriously
so that you can start to think about how
you can serve them
maybe the way that you will serve other
people and create value for them is in
is
introducing them to someone else in your
network and so you you are still serving
them you're you're
still creating exchange of value and
that's what money is is an exchange of
value so
even if you don't actually have pounds
of dollars and so on
you still can create value for people
you can still make yourself wealthier
you could still
connect with through other value
creation
and and as you're doing that i think you
are still looking for people
who follow what um
warren buffett he has these three these
three words
uh they all start with i so i call it
the three eyes test now it's like who
you're looking to work with
is people that have high integrity high
intelligence and high initiative and i
wish i had had that
test 20 years ago that that that's such
a simple
clear test and so i just look now for
people that are high
high in all three eyes and when i find
them
i i just it's just so such a pleasure to
work with them
because you don't have to worry and
you're not well you know integrity
issues i don't know if they're going to
be honest with me they're going to say
one thing and do something else i mean
that's exhausting if you're working with
somebody in that
capacity if you find somebody that's
high intelligence that means they can
figure things out means that there's
high processing abilities i don't i
don't mean
what their resume says they went to
school and i mean can they do stuff are
they capable
and then the third in some ways it's the
thing i most long for
is high initiative because that's that's
so much more effortless if you're
working with somebody who's got a high
initiative
because the effort really what effort is
is mental exertion it's having to think
about something with your article is
that you have to think
um you know think about which articles
to get think about what you want to say
about each
of these books think about you know all
of that is that's the efforts mental
exertion if you've had some with high
initiative
they're doing the thinking for you so
i mean i suppose i've just given a list
of of how to find people that you want
to work with but i'm just wanting to
distinguish that you don't have to
pay the person you certainly don't have
to hire them full
time and that's that's a more unusual
step for people especially as they're
starting out
uh but there's so many services
available now that weren't before you
can go on fiverr
you can go somewhere else somebody that
a very low price point you can
test you could see that is this a good
fit as you're as you're starting
you know launching your business um i
suppose the only other thing i wanted to
say about
effortless results is that um
[Music]
is that you can apply it i mean i'll
give you another entrepreneurial
application
is a way you learn uh if you
learn as like there's two different ways
of learning
one way of learning is what what you
were almost almost all of us have been
taught in school
which is here's the content
it's going to be a test you're going to
be tested on approximately this stuff so
review that stuff try and memorize that
stuff try and
you know reproduce that for a moment
it's not i'm not like all negative about
that
you are going to learn if you do that
but it is
limited value because you are really
learning something
once to apply it once you know you
memorize the stuff
you go take the test that is your reward
for having learned it
and then you forget it because it's
served its purpose that is linear
learning
um residual learning is completely
different
i remember elon musk was once
interviewed
and asked i mean it was a bit of a
leading question but he was basically
asked look how have you learned
so much so fast because what people
don't know about
musk is that he you know before he
started
spacex and tesla he had no background
in in mechanical engineering just think
of that
he had no background in in you know in
rocket science so people don't know that
they assume that that was his background
he didn't know anything about those
subjects well exactly
he certainly didn't have degrees in them
and so he has to
he is he has managed to upgrade his
thinking
you know enormously uh in order to be
able to then
not just be in those fields but in fact
you know push the limits and expand the
knowledge within those fields
and he was asked how have you how have
you managed to do that so fast and so
and he said he said well i'd like to
think about this as a semantic
tree he says it says knowledge is a
semantic tree
and it means by that that the trunk of
the tree are the first principles the
things that the core
principles of this new industry
he says you've got to get really clear
on that if you can get the trunk of the
the understanding of the if you can get
the principles
clear once you have
a structure to add all the other
learning to and that's where he's saying
it's a tree you've got the trunk
and the branches and the leaves you can
add little new things you learn
onto a structure you have learned and
are confident in
but what i want to add to his answer is
that what it really does if you can
get to the principles that you like if
you can understand the principles of
whatever you're trying to do
you can apply it hundreds and hundreds
of times into the future
and so that's an example of like you
invest once
to understand it deeply but then you can
apply it in a thousand other situations
you don't need money to do that you can
achieve that result simply by saying
okay i'm going to study this but i'm
looking for the
the core principles so that i can adopt
them absorb them
into my mindset and then be have have
you know
same as manga you talked about maybe it
was before we started the interview but
the idea that you've got a worldly
wisdom that you get
if you've understood the principle
deeply you can apply it
in smart ways in whatever
entrepreneurial venture you're pursuing
what are some of the most important
principles that you use
oh that's a good question um
one principle for me is
well the principle is
that if you want to be 100 times more
successful in life
you need to be 100 times more grateful
um
as soon as you say the word gratitude i
think people go oh yeah yeah i think
i've heard that before
and it's like
that they say that because they they
haven't even scratched the surface of it
if they react that way they think oh
yeah i mean i've done a little gratitude
in my life and it makes me feel a little
better and it's like yeah that isn't it
at all
if you can be grateful in everything in
everything that happens to you
uh you will get 100x return of like the
results you want in life
i i i don't even hesitate to say that
we granted you is gratitude will make
attitude probably is one of the key
themes that runs like a golden thread
through
effortless state action and results
um if you can be
one of the tactics for this um developed
after
getting to know bj fogg of tiny habits
um and he he develops these uh these
habit recipes for the stanford design
behavior lab and uh a
habit recipe in its simple simplest
format is after i
x then i will why and
for this practice uh i have said okay
after i complain i will say something
i'm thankful for
and what i noticed when i first started
that is i complained a lot more than i
realized
like i really couldn't believe it
because i think of myself as being quite
positive and being quite grateful and
and optimistic and those things but i
just was amazed i just i just was like
all day long just complaining about
things
walk into the room oh you know children
why are you doing this why are you doing
that wait
you know just check chat with anna well
this meeting took longer than i thought
and this thing happened
and this is what i'm leading with as
soon as you add on like i wasn't i
didn't say okay i'm going to eliminate
all
complaining in my life that seemed
overwhelming but
every time you complained you just say
something you're thankful for say
something positive afterwards
and and we started then
after up to just it had an amazing force
about it
it just immediately had an impact on
everyone i would talk to just they
their life was better they would be they
would be more energized they would
talking enjoy talking to me a bit more
because it's not you know no one wants
to talk to someone who's complaining
you know they want to talk to someone
who's got is grateful and grateful for
them and
it just started this whole positive
self-fulfilling
like cycle of good
um and so even with our children
sometimes we'll play the game and
and they'll say i remember my someone's
time saying after you've complained okay
something you're grateful
i'm so grateful that my dad is making us
play this game
you know just like that like sarcastic
gratitude
and uh well that's the thing about
gratitude is you can't beat it
is that we all laughed it immediately
changed the feeling
and we were already we were already in
the positive state and so it just made
it easier to then carry on with
everything else in life that we wanted
to do
uh yeah
i mean i i could really go a long time
on this but like you can't overdo this
principle
it's good it's the right it's the
it's the state to be in in good times
and bad
if things are really really hard right
now somebody listen to this is
really hard gratitude will help you
if somebody is in a state of amazing
success
right which definitely these seasons
come for people they can have
more good happening to them there's a
huge risk when those things start to be
good you start become arrogant
you start to be full of yourself you
start you're still comparing massively
comparative because there's always
someone to look
to so always someone who's got more
followers more bigger podcasts and
bigger book more money more there's
always something
so so being more successful doesn't
suddenly make you more happy
um it's great threat in fact success
so being great great grateful in times
of success is a great antidote to the to
the sort of the pride cycle
of life where we get too full of
ourselves so in good times and bad
gratitude is like the
the optimal state and if i had to really
say
simply what i think the effort the state
is i think this is it it's a state of
gratitude
and and it's uh there's a whole theory
by barbara fredrickson called
the broaden the build theory where she's
identified that basically state produces
better relationships and better results
than the other way around people think
if i have great results and i have great
relationships then i'll
then i'll be in a good positive state
it's exactly opposite
you change the state and it starts to
change the relationships and the results
you're producing around you and this is
why i think it's just come back to it
again and again and i can summarize this
principle i should have
started with this because this is the
best way of saying it this is the
principle
if you focus on what on what you
lack you'll lose what you have
and if you focus on what you have
then you'll get what you lack that's the
principle
i love it i think it was you
that told me the last time that we spoke
uh about an example that was very
similar to that
and it stuck with me for so long just
thinking about the effect that being
grateful has on us
thinking about just how much of a
it's so polarized to so much
bad thinking so much of the malaise and
the ambient anxiety
and the external comparison game and i
could be here
and all of it goes away it's
every time that i learn a little bit
more about it and you said it before
it's like yeah yeah yeah
gratitude yeah journals on the morning
pages yeah yeah yeah yeah i've heard it
um
and every time that someone else comes
back
up i had susanna hallinan on the podcast
the happyologist
positive psychology expert she's episode
32 so she was
10 deep into this journey and she said
happiness
is built upon a foundation of gratitude
without gratitude you cannot have
happiness
and still now episode 32 coming back to
to bite me in the ass before you go i
want to go back to something that we
actually spoke about before we
started recording you talked about the
courage to be rubbish
and particularly why i love it is that
rubbish is a word only british people
are going to understand
so every american that reads it's going
to go what's rubbish
does he mean trash
[Laughter]
yeah i love it for that reason too that
it's uh it's a
such a such a nice british size
yeah yeah i love it for that reason too
yeah so about i got to comment on what
you just said though about like
that just reminds me of of another
phrase that benjamin hardy used when
when he was on the podcast and he said
it was based on a book i think he hasn't
this is co-authoring but it isn't out
yet but it's
it's on this principle of
it's the have gap are you are you in
yeah he says are you in the the gap
or the gain that's it i can't wait in
the game
ben if you're listening i listen to that
episode and it's one of those things
where
an author drops a book that they're
going to bring out and this concept was
so interesting and the book's still not
here so me and you
are on the same team who are both pissed
off that ben hasn't hurried up and
written
exactly get on with it now ben so
so this just on that his point about it
so it just supports what you were just
saying
entirely is that like if you
want to be happy you need to be in the
game
you have to look at what progress have i
made what's gone right
who have i become that i've grown it's
like you look at the progress
if you want to be happy if you want to
be unhappy
you just look at the gap and that's it
you can probably be successful either
way
but you definitely will not be happy if
you're looking at the gap all the time
and so it's about a ratio question what
percentage of your life are you in the
gap
what i haven't achieved yet what i
haven't accomplished what i haven't
become
and how much of you your time you
looking at what you have achieved and
have succeeded
and so on the gain or the gap i think is
a great summary of what
you know what we're trying to talk about
here but the good news is
about what we're saying about state
today is that
the moment you get into an effortless
state
the moment you are in a grateful state
for example
you immediately are not in a fearful
angry grudging comparative state
it's instant you can only be in one
state in a moment
so so the moment you're grateful even
where my son is sort of
sarcastically grateful it's already
happened it's already
moved and of course any in any moment
you could go back to
complaining and so on but but we we just
we've been emphasizing it just as a
family just this last this last couple
of days this week
at spring break for us and
uh and so i we've up the ante it's like
yeah you can
criticize complain but after three
things you're thankful for
and it's amazing to me it's amazing to
me
that that it works it just
works they start getting into arguing
about anything i mean
you can argue about anything in life
can't you it doesn't matter ridiculous
things
you get all focused on and it's what
does it is it brings the whole state of
the the culture that you're in the
environment you're in gets bring down
you've got some of this toxic on your
team it just brings everybody down it's
every but as soon as you have
that person starting to say something
they're thankful for it re-energizes the
room people just start smiling and
laughing it's an amazingly
fast fix do you know what sorry i'm good
i'm going to go on yeah we'll riff on
this keep roofing on this so i
started doing gratitude journaling
probably about
four years ago something like that three
or four years ago and what i found was
my natural state wasn't massively
grateful i think if you haven't done
formal gratitude practice it's actually
quite
weird like to do it if you're not
naturally if that's not your inclination
and if you're a you know a bloke from
the the north of the uk
then that perhaps i'm saying this isn't
this isn't the normal thing
this isn't the normal thing you know
that's interesting so
what i found was that after a while when
i
it's supposed to only take three minutes
in the morning and three minutes at
night but when i got to the
three great things that happened to me
today section
yeah it was taking 10 minutes because i
couldn't think of anything
and then what oh really what i found
over time
was that i during the day was
finding things to be grateful for
as a gift to my future self that night
so that i didn't feel like an idiot
when it came time for me to write them
down so actually formalizing
formalizing the gratitude made the
present experience of things
in the moment different as well because
it it
made me accountable to myself i was like
look i need i need to have this thing
and i think that's
that little story i often use that as a
justification for a formalized practice
now you've actually managed
to um formalize the practice into a way
that rides the crest of now
that's actually it's it's always
happening but
an equivalent would be to to have some
sort of accountability whatever it might
be the accountability can be your wife
or it can be
it can be a diary or it can be something
else but you need those triggers
yeah and i i i subscribe to all
everything you just said
i i i've been doing a gratitude journal
too daily i do it i do it from
it's like mental health for me it's like
no matter like
i really need it to do it at night
and i'm amazed at how
forgetful i can be and i'll sit there
okay
what what what are the big things i'm
grateful for today and in that
process at first i can say not just oh i
don't know what to write
i just forget that that morning that
same morning something
great happened at 9 00 a.m 10 a.m and i
it was amazing some events some
news something great happened and i just
couldn't even remember it
yeah the same day when i come to write
about it
so the practice i think is enormously
important something that i used to do
every week
before the pandemic i had it built into
my routine
um was uh actually it was a church thing
i would do it there which isn't great
but i would do it at church i had like a
and and and then
pandemic no no one's going moments
meeting no one's doing so it removed
that
routine at my life and
just recently i've got back to doing it
each week where you summarize it for the
week
and i've been really surprised the
research is supports this that that
you'll get a bigger bump
of benefit if you do gratitude
lists on a weekly basis than even on a
daily basis
i do both now i don't think they're
mutually exclusive at all but
but doing it on the week what that does
is you get to sense
i think a bigger set of progress you get
to see a bigger sense of wow yeah look
at all those things
they added up and look at this so you
have a
more satisfying sense of of of progress
i think yes to all of these
you i don't know that you can overdo
this principle i i don't i don't see it
i believe thoroughly that if you want to
achieve
a hundred times the results you have in
your life you just you just say okay i'm
going to be that much more right
the gratitude to yeah to everyone to
everything in the bad things
too when things happen that are bad well
i'm glad
i've done this before i'm i'm thankful
that i survived this thing today i'm
thankful that this thing is done
and over i'm thankful that
somebody um this happened yesterday
somebody
somebody sent me a private message on on
linkedin that was negative
it's like pretty harsh actually about
something i just posted
and when i come to write about that i'm
thankful that they wrote to me
and said this they said something that
was critical
and sometimes as i'm writing for the
things you wouldn't necessarily normally
think to be grateful for i don't know
what i'm going to say for why i'm
thankful this happened
because because it was an act of faith
to write the first sentence because you
don't know why
but in the moment you start to go yeah
because
because i i hadn't thought about that
angle before i'm not
sensitive enough to that and so i was
able to which i did
re-write post that i'd just done with
more context to it
and even though i didn't enjoy in the
first moment of that
it was teaching and it was an
opportunity and being grateful for it
just means
that you see that the learning and the
benefit from it i mean you can't control
but if you can be grateful
in whatever comes the good and the bad i
mean you you like
it's like a superpower i mean a person
who can turn a negative into a
positive can never be defeated
that's what the effort the state gives
you
whatever comes fine the next big
challenge it's all right
because we know how to turn it into
something good
do you know what it feels like so people
use nasim taleb's anti-fragile
principle um for things like this but i
actually don't think that that's
necessarily perfectly correct
i actually think that this feels a lot
not
softer it feels more fluid than that
and a good example of this actually is
what's happening
what will be happening right now as
we're recording this so
um i had jordan peterson on the show
last night earlier on this week
marvel comics featured someone that
looks suspiciously like his philosophy
as the um principles beneath red skull
the magical super nazi that's the enemy
of captain america
so basically tanahasi coates that was
the the particular
author of the the comic book was saying
jordan peterson
is uh he has some analogies between this
for
his philosophy and that um so today
jordan has released a bunch of hail
hydra which was the the thing from
captain america which looks like the
hydra head from above
but he's changed it into a lobster and
put hale lobster
he's released them on posters and
t-shirts that are limited edition and
all the proceeds go to charity
and he put a tweet out yesterday that
had 40
000 likes on it something like that so
what he's done is he's taken
something which has happened and said
okay
how not only how can i perhaps deal with
this but how can i find gratitude that
this is now an opportunity
for me to do it and yeah there's some
particulars with regards to his platform
that permit him to
have more degrees of freedom with things
like this but
presumably somebody lower down the
status hierarchy or the um
the clout hierarchy their challenge
would similarly be down regulated
in kind so yeah seeing stuff like that
when people take something that
ostensibly should be
quite a bad day being called out by the
biggest comic on the planet for being
the
underlying philosophy behind a magical
super nazi
probably doesn't rank on every author's
like this is a this is a good day
yeah but now it seems really charming
the
the based on what i'm seeing online it
looks like the public opinions massively
in his
in his favor and whatever is chosen
charity some
homeless homeless children in canada
something
they're going to get just some insane
amount of of donations so yeah
that's a for a tacit example there right
courage to be rubbish what does the
courage to be rubbish mean
yeah courage to be rubbish is um well i
i've got to share a story about it
the the there's a british industrialist
henry cramer's
1959 he wants to support and accelerate
progress
on um human-powered flight
so this is like 50 years after the the
wright brothers have
actually successfully flown in a you
know in an engine-powered
uh plane but no one's done human-powered
flight so basically a bike inside of a
of a plane and he thinks he thinks this
is going to be doable i mean this is
only like 10 years before
uh you know neil armstrong is on the
moon so it doesn't seem crazy to him
that they can do this so he sets this
thing 50 000 pounds
quite a lot of money even now but it's
so it's a lot in 1959
go uh all sorts of teams get involved
well-funded
uh you know impressive brains all this
and for 17 years they fail
just know just nothing enter paul
mccreedy
who comes in he's in debt he doesn't
have money for a team
uh he has just basically his friends and
family
in fact he has his young son become his
test pilot
what am i doing today no don't worry
don't worry soon just keep your helmet
on it's gonna it's gonna be all right
it's gonna be all right son
so he's staring at the problem why i'm
not people been able to make more
progress on this and he suddenly
realizes everyone's been trying to solve
the wrong problem
they're all trying to build these really
beautiful machines
elegant you know wooden ribs plastic
casings all this just just beautiful
things great
teams great minds all this in order to
you know they have to they have to do
this half a mile
flight two mile flight something around
these two pylons without stopping and
that's what they're focused on and he
goes no it's exactly opposite what you
need is an
ugly as they come thing that can
crash and be rebuilt cheap
and fast that's that's the real problem
to be solved if we can solve that then
we'll be able to learn
so much faster and then be able to
figure out how to do this
so they built this thing totally ugly
looks looks amateurish
uh it was really light uh it would they
go they
tried to fly it would crash they just
grab
some broom handle uh you know stick it
back on and uh within five minutes
they'd be back up in the air he said
that the the
the competitive teams would take six
months
from that sort of setback they'd tried
to fly the plane it would crash
okay ship it back would take it back to
the university take it back to the
institute let's rebuild what we're doing
six months of of downtime between their
learning cycle
uh compared to him with five minutes
they they would maybe have
more crashes in one day than
some of their competitors would have in
the lifetime of the machine
and so it's on their 223rd attempt that
they
succeeded they won the first kramer
prize and went on to win two years later
they crossed the english channel
uh and won the second kramer prize for
100 000 pounds i mean this is like this
huge breakthrough but the breakthrough
wasn't
an aeronautics breakthrough primarily
the primary breakthrough was that you've
got to
make failure as cheap as possible
and and and there's a whole variety of
ways that you can do
that i mean you can make you can make
failure cheaper
by protecting it from the critic in your
head this is the way you
talk about your own performance when you
make a mistake
um you you when
you can i have a friend super you know
high capability high intelligent
business needed his
jd uh maybe jd mba i can't remember now
at stanford went on and did another phd
at princeton he's super smart teaches
spanish to other people and he just says
listen you you get it's like you gotta
imagine you have a thousand beads
and every time you make a mistake try to
speak spanish you get to take a beat out
and once you've done a once you've got a
thousand beads out you're gonna be
you're gonna be level 1 mastery in
spanish you just got to go out there and
make mistakes whereas some people want
to i've got to learn it get really good
before i ever use
the what i know the courage to be
rubbish is where it's in that that you
learn
everything starts rubbish every
masterpiece started rubbish they just
started they had the courage to do
you know the bad version of the article
there's so many people i meet so many
people who say i want
but this idea they have in their heads i
think the this trying to
do the wrong thing they're trying to
solve the wrong puzzle they're trying to
be perfect out the gate
these like perfect beautiful machines or
they they they think oh
everything i do needs to be oh i'd call
like baby
baby yoda perfect right from the
beginning
it's all it's just all cute and polished
and so on
but actually like at pixar for example
to play a little on that
that metaphor that they they believe in
and
articulate ugly babies we we love ugly
babies
because the first the first
you know the first sketch of
any idea the sketch is bad the idea is
bad
you know that you can go and see i've
seen them at pixel when i've worked with
the company they have
enshrined these early versions of toy
story and so on and they are
rough and they do look bad genuinely
without they're saying of course we want
that you've got to protect those you've
got to look after those things
so that you can ever get into into you
know better performance later
so you want to make failure as cheap as
possible
actually one of the things that we've
talked about already just following
through that thread is is one way to
make
make failure cheaper is just be grateful
along the way
i i just was talking to john um
uh acuff who's just come out with a book
called soundtracks
and he's basically saying we have all
these negative soundtracks in our mind
that get in the way and we have to
choose a better
you know better playlist and play a lot
so they become our most played
soundtracks and one of the soundtracks
that he said i just find it here he said
he's picked up this you either succeed
or you have a story
and i love that right if you you succeed
or you have a story meaning
i say he gave me this story he said that
when he was early starting off and
trying to market
he hired space at a conference he wasn't
even speaking at
and he just thought he just had this
idea that because of his success of his
blog and so on that loads of people
would come and meet him there and
whatever so he got
a thousand flyers made up that he would
have to be when they arrived and he sits
there
he's expecting all these people and
literally two people come
and one of them is a friend of his that
he knew was coming and
i think the other one was the person he
brought with him and so
he has a photograph of this now and he's
put it on it put it on his blog this is
from years back but he just tells the
story
and and that's what he's saying he says
one of the most popular blogs he's ever
written
you either succeed when you take an
action or you have a story and so this
is all about
trying to make it cheaper to for us so
you can
fail but it becomes cheaper i said a
little
a little differently it's how to make
life into an asymmetric
bet so that there's low downside
and high upside and if you can make your
life like that if you can
again to use the phrase if you can make
it a little more effortless
then then you can keep taking action my
mother was especially good at this
yeah she has we all have our strengths
and weaknesses but she was really good
at encouraging
uh well try it what's the worst that can
happen it's okay
and so it reduced the emotional burden
of what if i do this and i fail i'll
look stupid i'll be terrible i was worse
than dying and a lot of people
feel like that they just rather die than
than look stupid or do something and uh
and i didn't i just didn't grow up with
that burden
and i'm sure that meant that i actually
did look a bit more stupid than you know
than the average person more times
i didn't care and i don't care now
either and so it means
what i think it produces you know
speaking from personal experience for a
moment is that
it produces a sense of i'm game for that
let's try it
let's go let's go and then we'll learn
and we'll we can pivot fast but we're
going to learn let's go
and you just you're just not going to
learn or progress
if you're so worried about being perfect
that you don't
that you can't even take the first step
imagine if a baby
really literally somehow was embarrassed
that they
that first attempt they have to move to
crawl to sit up to stand they
they were being punished for that
imagine how ridiculous that would be
uh they get praised for it encouraged
for it we need to do that for ourselves
we need to do it for other people if we
want
progress and we do and if we want
progress to be even easier which we
really do
what i love is the idea of seeing
failure as the end in itself and
almost the thing that you're that you're
aiming to get to
not that the outcome i want from this
experiment is failure
but that you re-purpose failure you
rebrand it as okay failure is not
a bug it is a feature of this
undertaking that i'm going through now
and every single time that i fail one of
those beads comes off on the
on the the podcast string or on the
i'm going to be a dancer or i want to be
a rugby player or i want to
go to the business i want to get an mba
or i want to get phd i want to get a
college degree i want to be get a job i
want to do whatever every time that i
don't get a job
because you're going to get rejected
from more interviews than you're going
to be accepted because you're only
ever going to be accepted once um right
every time you get rejected okay cool
so what what what did i learn from this
what a privilege it is how fortunate
am i to be able to now be even better
than that
and it removes
the emotional attachment that we have to
the desire to always be
correct and moving forward and looking
cool and not blundering and falling over
it's like no no everybody's blundering
and falling over blundering and falling
over
is it's built into the source code of
what you're going to do in fact you're
probably going to blunder and fall over
far more than you're going to succeed
and every single time that that happens
you can be grateful for it you can be
thankful for the fact that you now get
to come back
and perhaps be a little bit better at
avoiding
that blunder when i was reading that
courage to be
rubbish section it reminded me of a
tweet a couple of tweets actually that i
saw this year
and this one's from thiago forte and he
says
a paradoxical thing about people who
consistently choose the most high
leverage activity
is that efforts have a rough edged
half-assed quality
because polishing things to perfection
is a low leverage activity
and someone replied to it and said
perfectionism is a nice way to hide from
shipping at a pace
necessary to find what works
well the co-founder of linkedin
reed hoffman first of all he says
if you aren't embarrassed by the first
product you ship then you waited too
long
um and and he applies that not just in
sort of startup strategy but he
hired a new chief of staff
he said to ben i'm comfortable with a
10 to 15 percent foot fault rate
if it allows us to move fast i accept
that you will make decisions
plenty of times that wouldn't be what i
would do in that situation
but i want us to be moving fast that's
the that's the value
and and ben is on record saying well
that just freed me just liberated me to
go
forward to not be so hesitant not
waiting all the time and and that's
really what
one of the things that people that i
think keeps people back from doing
what's most essential in their lives
doing the things that really matter to
them that they feel actually a pull
towards
is that they have another counterweight
pulling them back which says
yeah but don't do anything stupid and
don't do anything that
that would that could make you
uncomfortable or don't do anything that
could be a failure along the way
and so then they just don't do anything
they don't go anywhere
and and and that's i think is a far
bigger risk
especially i mean we're talking about
progress progress over perfectionism
every day of the week i love it
greg it's been an absolute pleasure
having you on effortless
is out on april 27th
april 27th the link to either pre-order
or purchase right now will be in the
show notes below
where should people go you've got so
much stuff going on at the moment where
it's best for people to keep up to date
with everything
i think if they sign up for the
newsletter they'll definitely not lose
anything we have a one minute wednesday
um you can sign up at greg mcewen.com
g-r-e-g-m-c-k-e-o-w-n
dot com also essentialism.com that's
where the whole academy is getting
launched there's a 21-day
challenge that just tries to make it
really micro bite
sized master classes each day but it's
just like little vignettes
to help people make progress on what
really matters most to them
and there's this whole series of classes
coming there that people can take and be
part of
i think i would i think i would go with
those greg mcewen ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for coming on
thanks chris thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace